what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
[Music]
[Applause]
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know if you have subscribed to two
or watched two or more of my videos and
you do not subscribe we have beef okay
beef on top of that guys today's sponsor
is cooking with chris cooking with chris
offers completely customizable meal plan
so basically you give the guy what you
already like to eat and he makes you a
custom-made meal plan just for you i'm
down 20 pounds on this meal plan the
only reason i sponsor it like every
episode is because i literally love it
so the link to that is in the
description
so um today we have some special guests
on the channel
why don't we go around everyone say your
name your age where people can find you
and your relationship status
[Laughter]
i'm 27 years old you can find me on the
shambles fm podcast
uh it's on tik tok youtube and all your
platforms and i am single
um my name is yasmin i'm 22. you can
find me on instagram at i am yazzy.xx um
and i'm in a situationship
my name is telvin you can find me on
youtube tik tok
tj's world and i'm 27 and i'm i'm single
uh i'm toby uh i'm 26.
you can find me on also at shambles fm
on youtube tik tok whatever you're using
you know only fans all of that and um my
perks shut up
we're branching out we're branching out
we're branching out uh yeah and my
personal ones in there too so yeah thank
you
my name is amani i'm 22. um taken and
you can find me on tiktok at imani
underscore xox
okay guys so just so you guys know um
all super chats donated today will be
read by the by the panel so if there's
something you guys like want us to
answer or say um
put it give us a super chat and we'll
read it um okay second off today's topic
is
um modern women are forever single
um so when you guys hear a modern woman
like the word modern woman what do you
guys think of
a woman who works
a woman who works um
yeah yeah yeah you know oh yeah i'm
independent don't need no man type [ __ ]
um
yeah woman works really i think that's
what i kind of associate with more than
women i feel like a modern woman is
probably someone or woman who
respects her morals and values
honestly i feel like her wonder woman
has her own stuff yeah i mean like her
own apartment her own
job her own car like everything's paid
for by her okay what do you think of a
modern woman is one in my eyes that will
put career before the traditional like
things like
start a family you gotta do this you
gotta do that
and just like
yeah just like a woman that
basically values i guess getting her own
bag above
a family life and like security and all
that sort of stuff so do you guys think
that um when women put the career before
the family that it leads to like them
being happy in the long term
it depends on what they want i think i
think i think yeah
because
oh yeah
um i think yeah because you know like
when we used to depend
on like getting money from men when like
we divorced and stuff we we had to take
money from the man in order for us to
survive because we never had a job but
now if we divorce we don't even have to
split anything half half we could just
like live
like comfortably after a divorce and
stuff like that but now if the woman's
smart she'll still do that so you're
still i just feel like money
if he's making more than you yeah but
because you have that right they they do
this thing nowadays where they sign a
prenup so you don't actually get to take
them but you can still be a modern woman
and not sign a prenup and still take
their money yeah
because i'm in me personally no i hear
that i hear that and i'm out of here
what i mean but i mean like if
she if she was in a place where she
didn't have a job and stuff like that
um would wouldn't she be more like she
won't be able to survive
sorry she will be able to survive on
just his money she'd have to like come
out of her comfort zone and get a job
and but let's say i do have a job but
i'm making
less than my significant other because i
don't have a printer but i can still
take that money yeah you can i can still
be happy why can't i still do that and
most of the time the woman is going to
be earning less or around the same
because women don't date down
yeah women don't work out below below
the level they're on
they want them to someone to be higher
majority so if um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no but
[Laughter]
she don't want it she's like i want to
make sure i'm good after divorce you're
like i want to make sure we don't get
divorced
you know what i mean yeah but he's on
the point of the women's earning more
not the man anymore in her situation
do you know what i mean like i can kind
of see where he's coming from because
statistically speaking um
women earning more will end up leading
to the force that's not the sustain same
statistics as her i just feel like for
me
no i'm just saying for me personally i
just feel like a woman should have like
her money tucked away for anything
because at the end of the day wait for
me
like we need to have no because
okay wait wait
so you think
let's say when you let's say your man
yeah
how long have you been together for six
years
whoa
i did not see that coming
how old are you
all right
[Music]
um
so when you go on a date it's 50 50.
all the time yeah if
well obviously sometimes he'll pay or
sometimes i'll pay
but
so it's like the different yeah it's
different but even if i was to go out in
like if god forbid if we break up like
and i was to go out into like a date and
situation i'll pay 50 50. 100 would you
i'll pay for my staff no you're lazy no
yeah no
100 would you pay 50 50.
if you won on a date would you pay 50
50. 100
why would they not pay 50 50.
no but why wouldn't i wait
hold on hold on if they offer to pay
yeah
i'll be like do you are you sure you
don't want me to pay some yeah continue
to say no
yeah you pay them okay
i don't know
i understand i understand
however
wow
however i'm paying if you did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
are they all oh
um
i guess we're coming back tomorrow
are they plugged in
put on yours again paul
yeah it looks like this plug
um
testing
people it's all good
good
um
okay so you can hear me now guys
if they're still saying no they're
trying to
they're still saying they can't hear me
i don't know why
not controlling the trolling
okay wait so what were you guys talking
about
i think we spoke about um i don't know
how we got
retired
okay so so because i was hearing you
guys wanted to work the rest of your
life why
no
what we came to the conclusion was that
toby said okay cool so
came up to you and gave you what 1.2
million pounds whatever he said 2.5 iso
um
why would you continue to work yeah yeah
and i said some people just like working
and at that point
it would be more of a hobby right than
you actually working because you're
doing something that you're enjoying not
something that you would have to yeah to
get money you're getting money from it
and you were saying that like most
people don't have jobs they like yeah
yeah like if someone comes to you and
gives you that money to retire
if you say
you're just gonna keep working right
grinding away or something you don't
like the job you're at it's like you're
not yeah you're not you're gonna chill
because what because the moment you pay
for something extravagant and you see
your account there's still bear money
left in there you're gonna get lazy
you're gonna get lazy
trust me trust me i just think there's a
difference between like having to work
and like get like wanting to work you
know what i mean 100 and i think and i
think most girls and most girls like
don't want to have to work yeah
the argument okay i was like who won who
do you think
he contradicted himself just to let you
know why did he no no oliver
i won that [ __ ] yeah
the next part of it was
i said that if i was in a relationship
with a girl and she said i'm going to
retire you i said there's no way
you wouldn't let a girl retire you
that's not because
from the moment she retires me the
relationship's finished right due to
fail yes that's what i was saying like
as a woman yeah it's different well
girls will lie they'll be like oh baby
like that that won't actually happen but
like
80 to 90 percent of the time we leave
when that when we out earn the guy
yeah but i said you were so hardcore
agreeing with his point and then you
said that
because i literally said the same thing
but in the opposite way
i was good with his point because i'm
saying it's different for the man and
the woman i'm saying from the man's
point of view
of you
i i think it's straight cap when someone
comes to retire you
you're gonna do stuff yeah of course
like everyone's free to do what they
want like everyone has their own
internal like ambitions yeah yeah but to
say you're gonna like work like grind as
hard as you're gonna you're probably not
going what if i want to make like
right i mean you can you can want to but
women aren't doing that like i don't
know what it is in the uk but in the u.s
the average woman makes like 42 40 000
per year if someone gives me two mil 2.5
mil
yeah yeah
if someone if someone gives me 2.5 mil i
could
turn that into five mil right easily
then why the wait wait how much
you're saying you can make two point
five to five why haven't you done it hmm
i haven't done it why haven't i because
i don't have i do not have two point
five mil
you have you have you have 25 pounds
yeah no i hear that but i could take
more risks when i have like a lot more
money see i think that's a really
no i'm so sorry guys
that's like i can't buy a house now
i would definitely buy houses and sell
it i'm saying oh you could just be tall
i'll go to the nba
like no i i hear that
i feel like it opens more opportunities
when you have money
mba nfl players go broke like if you
can't manage a thousand dollars how are
you going to manage a house no no i hear
that
that's why i'll continue to work even if
i get that money yeah but it's just like
the question is why do we push working
on girls
when that doesn't make us happy what do
you mean like again women that are
affordable over the age of 45 and that
are single and childless are the most
medicated do you know the average age
for retirement 65.
so like
we spend half of our life being like old
yeah you know so
what like what is there after 40 when
you don't have a career i mean when you
don't have a family
yeah in fact and the reason i was making
like
what i was making kind of like
guys
i thought was different for guys because
guys have to have that innate thing of
like
i have to i have to work because
we kind of valued on
a number of things and one of those
things is how much money we earn the
reality is if you're a guy you're broke
your age like the world sees you as you
ain't [ __ ]
if you're a
obviously there's there's still things
like okay you might not want to use that
then it comes out the morals and stuff
but the reality is you can still get in
certain doors because
yeah from looks where the guy is like
there's so much
i don't mean anything i agree and i've
seen pretty woman i know how it goes
game magic
you seen it
my ex you oh
thank you
with your eyes
she said she
so that didn't happen
oh she was in a strip club
it sounds kind of mad for me still um
anyway anyway okay so another another
thing about about modern women is they
say there's no such thing as
a hoe basically and there's no such
thing as [ __ ] shaming
do you guys think that body count should
matter
a hundred percent
wait for the
girl girls they forgot actually let's
say for girls first because we're
talking about modern women yeah
um
yes yes
now she's thinking
no no i do think it matters i do to to
specific things are you a modern woman
i don't know what that means
i respect my moles i have respect my
morals and values yeah that was my
definition at the beginning
so what's your perception
not something that's in line
[Music]
i'm more like you know i'm very much
knowledge is power like i want to know
type [ __ ] especially if i'm serious
about you i want don't give me no [ __ ]
like
i don't know so do you ask girls yeah
how many really i ask you do you think
they tell you the truth
i'm quite i'm quite i feel
um
i like to make people relax sort of
thing shut up
but i'll just make people relax i feel
like especially i wouldn't ask you some
dumb time on a date or awesome we're in
bed and i'm gonna ask all right
now that now that i've added to
honestly i've seen some [ __ ] like people
i swear did you see
you know i like i ask a lot of questions
i don't really care but i'm very open so
i'll tell you the same [ __ ] yeah like i
wouldn't lie to someone okay what's your
body count
your opinion that's crazy
we're
[ __ ] yet bro i'll tell you yeah that's
presumptuous oh sorry yeah my bad we
haven't you got a channel
[Laughter]
to the show
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you guys want to move on to me yeah
yeah okay um i think um it matters more
for guys
like when they're getting into like
serious relationships and stuff mm-hmm
but if
i don't know if the girl just doesn't
want to get in a relationship and she
just wants to do whatever she wants to
do like it doesn't really matter
but so why do you guys think it's
different for for men and for women body
count
experience
because
experience i think it has everything to
do with how it was back in the days
how it was back in the days like we're
talking about hundreds of years ago you
know what i mean and i feel like from
then reputation has been built up to
women should be like this and then when
we're trying to be like actually no
there's still that kind of well you
realize it's our biology
would you in regards to what like
because you seem to blame it on society
i'm not blaming that okay like why yeah
like why yeah that's what i'm asking but
it's like more biology because like
historically men had to ensure paternity
to make sure that the genes were theirs
and so like if a girl slept with more
people then they didn't know if the kid
was theirs and they were passing on
their legacy to someone else's kid but
isn't that still society
no it's your bio the same way like girls
are hypergamous so they tend to want a
guy that makes more money because
historically that meant he could take
care of us right so um it's not it's not
society it's like our biology right but
you're from what i can understand and
correct me from wrong yeah um you're
saying that the men would have to find
out or needs to ensure that the
kid is his yes right why
why
well no i'm saying i'm not saying that
he well
nowadays you can just do a dna test yeah
but they still say 20 to 30 percent like
up to 20 to 30 percent of
kids like are not
like that's not yeah yeah like women
just like lie and
it's 20 to 50
it's not society it's our biology it's
like the same with like girls like tall
guys because we want a guy that can
protect us right i'm six foot
so like if you're under like
a certain height it's cooked it's over
for you
and um but it's like it's not because a
society told me to think this way it's
because like i'm naturally attracted to
you yeah you know i agree yeah yeah i i
do think it's historical
um
but in the sense that
like survival of fitness type [ __ ] so
i think if you're a woman with a
if you're if you're a man of a high body
count it means you know you're more
attractive to other women more people
want you type of thing yeah i think if
you're a woman with a hype i i
personally think and you know i've told
you like women get to choose i don't
choose who i sleep with the women says
yes and no women control sex hundred
percent i don't i can do whatever i want
i can but more time it's men shooting
their shot at let's say ten women in a
club
two three depending on what you look
like maybe ten say yes
[Music]
these days
um no i think but if you're a woman ten
man might be shooting a shot at you yeah
you just pick one right you can't pick
more than one can you some girls yeah
you can you can you might lose three
four man in a club you'll go home with
one yeah you know what i mean
huh
are you a trained type of girl is that
your thing oh girl
i didn't even swing that way you said or
two you said word too faced with some
people that i've seen some people don't
see
them bring them up
but what so i'm i'm just saying i think
uh it is a woman's choice so she's gonna
pick over to her he's the alpha male
some people's a nice girl some people's
remember the money some people it's the
pretty boy some people is the one that's
gonna throw them all over the house you
know what i mean yeah so it really
depends on what you're you know what
butters your biscuit that's what you're
gonna choose to take home with you yeah
that's what that's how i think yeah
that's why i think um
where body count matters so if you're
like out every day you're choosing
different man
that means you can't keep a guy right
how do you mean like if a girl has a
high body count it means she can't keep
a guy
no not necessarily because they could
decide to be hot just they just decide
to be like a hoe in it yeah but i think
most girls it was
i think most girls want
like
the highest value guy they can get
so either they're sleeping with betas
i hate that word or like i think every
girl she has the guy she wants to be
with also he's going to want to lock him
down i thought a lot of people are dumb
sorry
a lot of girls do social proofing
yeah which are friends yeah like if for
example the guy that the lonely looking
guy
isn't going to get that much attention
but a guy he could be quiet but if he's
like he's around a certain group or like
he has people around and people you can
see people like like him a warm person
they're gonna go towards that person i
mean or in certain situations they'll be
like okay some the girls like him or
think of a club situation in that club
you've seen you've seen two guys
bottles bare girls around them i've
never seen two girls in bear man
100
oh actually
i haven't seen that i haven't seen it
you talking about your two girls club
situation two girls with a bad man on
them
[Music]
yeah i don't know
i think i think different things attract
different yeah men have different
qualities men have their qualities that
women are attracted by men of women have
different qualities and men are
attracted by i think yeah body count
does come into that but i feel like it's
like a desire type thing
i think
as a man
as a man i feel like if more women
desire you
it's just increasing the amount of women
that desire you yeah i mean it's like a
circle well it goes back to like
pre-select like historically like
if we saw that a guy could take care of
other women
then we would want him because like he
showed that he could take care of other
women so then you want him more
so it's like biology go ahead and
guys have to also the first move
you don't mind for 2022 do you have to
use most of the time i'm going to do not
all the time now though that's fine
majority i feel like
no don't catch it
let's say we're out you have a man okay
fine so your vision on it might be a bit
warped so i kind of don't want to ask
you because you're going to say yeah you
haven't been single for six years okay
ever since you're a teenager so
respectfully you haven't been out there
to even shoot your shot maybe you've
cheated no but i've i shot my shot to
get with my boyfriend right now i shot
the first night you were 15.
okay
would you
today
shoot your shot if you if you liked
somebody you were like it's a bit of me
would you shoot your shot would you just
stand there trying to look pretty making
eyes no i'll shoot my shot you'll go up
and be like why gone a hundred percent
girl's version of shooting but the thing
no one like on instagram
is
no he was in the comments hey
how'd you shoot that's what i want to
see
well he he had like a following so i
just made a video saying i wanted to
meet him
and that was quite good and then he
lived like i knew that's directly
that's indirect you're not actually
telling him i want to meet you no i
didn't he did i did what do you mean
wait wait in the video wait did you make
a video and push on your ticket yeah
yeah i think it's a little indirect how
was that indictment
that's direct okay we're not playing
with words right now she directedly
acted on the video yeah i was like i was
like oh i didn't notice this like crater
was kind of cute we should like hang out
like i don't know how how direct could i
be in his dms what are you in his dms oh
no was that well after i like i sent him
the video
okay okay that's directly yeah yeah yeah
oh thank you
that's the thing arthur though i'm just
saying that's just my opinion that's
funny when a girl does it it's cute
you're [ __ ]
i remember oh my god this is a while ago
now but i just remember
no
i was like i was going to take it down
like the next day if it didn't if he
never slashed
no it was longer than that because well
because he had such a big following so i
figured he might not see it so i was
like i may give a couple things it's
kind of embarrassing i mean i'm in more
than one video
i was like
like it works though we did it for a
year i mean not well but like we did
think that is an hour w i don't know
don't be pearl in the chat man
um
so so you guys think that's slut-shaming
you would agree like it should be a
thing right
it should be no i don't know
for women or in general
for women i think women should be shamed
videos on twitter saying
everybody this girl's a [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you want to get your dick so i'll go
hold her at her cause she's going to do
that
okay
oh
my god that girl shouldn't have put
herself in that situation huh that girl
shouldn't have witnessed
[Applause]
like a lot with a lot of different
people yeah
why no but
i don't know because it decreases your
value as a woman yeah but if she doesn't
want to be a valued woman if she just
wants to sleep
around there is girls there are
strippers
wait
i'm so sorry exactly that's different
okay okay okay okay yeah i hit it out
here
you are working you might like sex yes
there's also girls that i'm not for
money yeah okay but there's also girls
that are not always
are included workers people people are
they slots though
no you have to be slightly all right
that's what i'm saying so you're working
so that's don't count yeah no i didn't
hit it i hit that but
i just think it's honest like i hate
because girls we lie to each other we
act like oh there's no such thing as
slut-shaming yeah then why is it the
first thing we do when we don't like a
girl we say she's a hoe i
know i don't do that girls girls do that
all the time
we should be undervalued for having sex
with multiple people right that's what
you said no i didn't say we should be i
said we all shouldn't we are yeah we
just we just went around the room and
asked guys like like body count matters
they said it matters therefore it
matters who we sleep with no but they're
saying slut-shaming yes yeah because
slut-shaming is honest
at least you're being honest with me
being honest about how many people you
sleep with uh-huh and not be slashing
for it do you know what i mean because
at the end of the day how what figure is
too much
but here's like i just think if you talk
about slut-shaming it's honest it's like
like at least you're being honest to
girls there's consequences
single player on their sons
on the sons basketball team she [ __ ]
some of them devin booker definitely got
head you know what i'm saying allegedly
that [ __ ] got head bro but what i'm
saying is yeah i imagine you didn't know
about that
i would want someone to tell me this
girl
she did this
hundred percent 100
i want to hear this [ __ ] about no
she did that she's empowered no don't
give me that [ __ ]
yeah i agree
and then 10 years a lot of sections that
age divided by two
the space between when you lost like
in the 81 now yeah
add that up yeah i had that by two
divided
[Music]
so let's say let's say it's like 10
years right but she was in a five-year
relationship does does that the body
count like then is it only for every
year she was single that you said two
three yeah yeah
actually
too much
so n plus one this
but it goes back to like at least you're
honest yeah but i think you can be
honest and not stop shame i don't think
for example having sex with multiple
people if that is the person that you
are you should be slushing for it and
that's right
well what is slut-shaming that's what i
was gonna say i think shame i think when
you're saying shame very much cersei in
game of thrones like
because i think i think no one can make
you feel ashamed someone could try to
shame me for having a youtube channel no
no no someone could try to shame me for
having a youtube channel i would never
feel any shame yeah because of who you
are no no it's because i know what i'm
doing isn't like there's nothing wrong
with what i'm doing you can only feel
shame if you know there's something
wrong with it
they're in the mud right now yeah like
we're still doing this right yeah like
it doesn't matter like anyone could say
anything about me i don't care because i
i know i know what i'm doing yeah but
i'm saying like
you can only feel that if you know you
did something wrong no i agree with you
but at the same time society puts so
much pressure for example these three
gentlemen here
put so much pressure on women not
sucking dick or not having sex
i'm saying they can do it just once in a
while you know
as long
when it comes down to
society putting pressure on these young
women it's hard for them to be like okay
is this right is this wrong because so
many decisions are based on societal
factors i think if we had one i don't
think society puts pressure on us to be
prudent like come on no i don't know we
don't want to be fruits what like to be
more like what are you saying society
makes us be more sleep with less people
or more no i'm saying society puts
pressure on women to not sleep with a
load of men
i don't think that's true when you see
when you see people
promoting only fans and promoting yeah
promoting like [ __ ] walks and promote
like yeah with your boogies
like body count doesn't matter like that
rhetoric's everywhere right so
but i think there's a part of us that
knows that's not true
so we can say this and we can say don't
shame
but like it's not honest so i would
rather
at least tell girls the truth and say
hey guys are disgusted by this behavior
if you do this people are going to call
you a [ __ ] they're going to call you
like like don't be that girl rather than
say do what you want and then what if
that girl does not give a [ __ ] oh she's
still a hug
then she's going to be shamed that like
it and you might not say it out loud but
you're thinking it
that's what it is it comes down to
being aware of the consequences because
right now people are doing things as if
there's no consequences yeah the
consequence is go sleep around do your
thing be sexually free that's fine sure
when it comes to when it comes time to
settle down you are not gonna get the
man that you want and you're gonna have
to settle for some guy that doesn't get
girls he's gonna be happy to settle
oh
yeah because we tell girls that you just
get a husband you don't have to earn him
so you have to earn i feel like you have
to own your partner there's there's in
the relationship you have to earn the
relationship would you
would you
let's say a mad only fans john no
ah you finish
oh
i'm working hard to get in those but
then my uncle can pay 5.99 to see
everything i'm saying oh no not anymore
not anymore anymore
yeah she retired
forever
and you know you're a chance of a hat
you're the life you
are
you know your chance of a happy marriage
so if you are a virgin and you get
married your chance of being happy is
eighty percent yeah i can believe that
well no no no so guess what it is after
five guys you've slept with
what percent of girls do you think have
slept with more than five guys
at least i would say at least 50 at
least yeah
i say 75 percent of women okay all the
way
of women how old 18 let's say let's say
the average age of first marriage is 27
so let's say 27 above
75 100 easy 80 yeah yeah okay okay so
your chance of having a happy marriage
after you've slept with five guys goes
down to thirty percent from eighty four
five five months five men and then it
goes down even further after ten
further after twenty five in a week so
like that's why i think we should have
shame in a society because at least
you're honest
how many how many girls are too many of
you
what's the percent of women that have
slept with
over five guys uh
what's the percent of women that have
slept with over five guys um there's not
good data on it because one is
self-reported so you're never gonna
really know
and two it's um
they don't do a good job of
doing the generations so like they take
they take data from everyone of all age
groups and that's not a good way to
collect data
um i think i think guys let me know in
the chat if there's a better study that
i don't know but the one that i saw last
like they don't
measure it very well okay what have you
lied about your body account before your
man no
one time my ex went through all of my
texts from the la i'm like i should not
tell the story i'm live
he never found anything i didn't tell
about okay i don't i don't lie okay i
just i don't i don't like liars what
about you yes man have you lied before
by your body count no i've been straight
honest with my body account yeah always
oh well you've yeah
yeah oh that's pretty boring but you're
a yes
are you sure you've been honest
me yeah yeah have you been lied
no
speak around in the running of the bike
no it's it's just i've i've lived a lot
of life
how are you 27
a lot of life a lot a lot of life i've
done a lot of life in it so some people
i've been honest with other people i
haven't been honest with you
why did you choose not to be honest i
wasn't honest when i was younger i
wasn't honest
okay
a few years ago yeah but why do you
still lie about having more would you
count or less okay cool i just wanted to
know but didn't you say that um do you
not do you know
i say that the more body counts that you
have the more appealing you be you are
to women yeah
so why would you bring it down no no it
gets to a point where it's like bro you
don't need to have any more
like you're done
you're good
like some people it's like something
like a lot
for example me i feel like when i'm
talking to a girl i'll sleep with the
guys
the main issue is stds
right yeah they're like i need to make
sure you're checked it makes you all
good so whenever that body count is
higher they're like
[Music]
that's true [ __ ] does he have satin
you know what i mean so it's more like
as much as desirable as you look there
are other things to take into
consideration
for the guys out of every 10 girls you
hook up with what percent make you wear
condoms
gonna be real
maybe like
one
what percent two
wait no one person you can't have one
center one or two ten out of ten one oh
so ten twenty percent okay ten twenty
percent
um
of this year
okay so i went i went to toronto
every girl made me wear a condom
it's very different so
canada girls oh my god i was like what
the [ __ ] is going on how many girls you
hook up with on this trip oh
i was there for a week
to be honest like it could have been
crazier i was quite tame i was hungover
a lot of time so you know i couldn't do
as much as i could have so you know very
chill
so so cool so many girls
three
four five oh i said i didn't see a
number
um
do you hear me you hear me say it no i
can't hear you
oh good yeah i said it dude you're right
i may be hugging you
maybe
i'll tell you after but anyway um
yeah so everyone out there made me wear
a condom
in london
in the uk they don't care
some
who's scared
it's like that it's like do you have
like i thought here is very much do you
have one no
okay
but at the same time that happened
was more like oh yeah
and then yeah i actually get older
one time
she looked at me like like i was
disturbed yeah oh my gosh so okay so you
know you know i'm gonna say her name but
um i'm going to explain her
two two
yeah um
so
she the first time i slept with her she
was like oh yeah oh so first i've said
with her i took out the condom how old
was i i was 19. i just found only set
with one other girl with a condom on
with without a condom changed my life on
my [ __ ] days if you ain't done it i
don't know where the camera is if you
haven't done it
[ __ ] you though
you ain't having sex i'll be so real
respectfully
but
took it so um first time i had ever
watching harry potter master calm condom
afterwards we're like chilling cuddling
she's like why did
why did you put a condom on
was that
huh
she was like he said do you think
something's wrong with me why did you
why did you wear one i was like
oh
i know we're playing that game right now
i i thought
obviously until 16 to 19 i've always won
one always weighs away
shut up
ever since yeah 16 90 i always won and
then
okay so so what percentage yeah we said
wait a second
i i'd say honestly
just taking this year probably zero
like but those are the ones that say
yeah wear it and then they tell you
halfway through go on and take it
isn't that kind of crazy though like
because it takes one wrong std
to not get you could not have kids
from it
no if a girl gets the wrong std she
can't have kids she can be infertile
later or pass on something to your kid
no i know one girl that said oh no i'm
not going to give you head without a
condom now because just in case
she was like scared of getting chlamydia
of the throat you know existed
i swear but but it's like it's like
that's why i think [ __ ] shaming should
exist let's shame this stuff out of
society no one just no one get chlamydia
over the throat
i just think it's more like honest
um
okay let's read uh i saw one super chat
so um i'm gonna read the first one and
then you can read the other one okay so
thank you for the a hundred dollar super
chat
okay um chris and pearl i think you've
noticed that many females will use
anecdotal examples to argue their points
do you think this stem stems from a lack
of understanding of data or statistics
or do you think this stems from a need
to win an argument
um
i think that girls operate more on
feelings and guys tend to operate more
on data like so anecdotal is more like
oh i have a friend that's that's what
i've seen
um what's the other one do you want to
read it
it disappeared on my phone
can you hear me yeah oh wait i don't
know a chat
can chat can you hear me
oh here's another one i'll just read
really quick um
anderlin plays games having a lot of
partners is easy for women that's why
they are ashamed men are admired for
having a lot of partners because it's
extremely difficult and then there
should just be one more
um so we have diego morales
i think women should work even if they
are married because depending on only
the man to live is not a reliable way of
thinking
if you can live with the man's income
just save it it will help you in the
long run
agreed
okay so
next question why is it socially
acceptable
for women to hate men but it's not
socially acceptable for men to hate
women
i don't know why but it's true i'm never
fooled by that
he's beyonce's father
she made one song
what song he won the world who run the
world i thought it was out for you gonna
say irreplaceable oh you know what you
know what that song
it's music
and a little bit of beginner
little bit a little bit if you like
megan i don't respect you respectfully
she's garbage
but anyway seriously charlemagne she
likes anime i like her
well why do you guys think that is
like why like we always hear things like
men are trash but like men can't say
women are [ __ ]
men do say women are [ __ ]
we're not allowed to out loud
like there's a million songs like why
men great till they gotta be like
there's a million songs like that like
but there's not we're the ones that's
actually some crazy [ __ ]
from women it sounds a bit
tongue-in-cheek
it's not like even though you might the
great amount it's like because of
patriarchs society we're never going to
be degraded ain't never taking men down
yeah i mean you can't you can't
but you think the patriarchy is real
yeah
how
um what is the patriarchy like in terms
of the patriarchy i think it's what we
see
that's what you see yeah um
what you see when you look around okay
in any company most companies uh-huh any
company that is going to succeed
any companies now okay it's gonna be in
ten years okay it's white men at the top
okay i'm saying
i think um and they're the ones that
make the rules even if we don't see okay
that are making the rules for example it
is then making the rules so but a
visible hand okay so
how is it
so if you would you say it's a
matriarchy in
industries where they're female
led no no
they still have to adhere to men's views
and men's rules and that's not true so
like in education that's mostly women
yeah nurses
who's the minister of education he funds
public schools who's the minister of
education i don't i'm in the uk i don't
know oh okay i don't know
i don't know i don't know
in america right and here right it's
still white men are making rules
it's women that are teaching yeah mm-hmm
cool like
yeah we have women teachers like forever
female teachers forever
but i think that's like
me i don't respect teachers personally i
don't [ __ ] with that
but but
so no no
but um what i'm saying is like
men when you're younger you're not told
to go be a teacher right you're not told
to do that like but for our women when
they're youngest you know you're talk oh
yeah be good
okay but you don't agree but look at the
children
but here's here's the thing though like
it's not like it's not society telling
us what to do i think what we see
no no no no there's been study after
study that's disproven this
if you if you if you make a list of the
countries where women have the most
choice and the least choice the pay gap
increases it doesn't decrease because
women pick jobs that have to do with
people and men pick jobs that have to do
with things it's about personality
differences
on top of that most women are agreeable
which makes you less money like 60 of
women have never asked for a pay raise
in their life no and they quit before
they ask for a pay raise
so it's not it's not a patriarchy
because because women pick those fields
but no no you're saying it's not a
patriarchy
even the women's pick those fields a
patriarchy still means that men stand to
the top yeah right but
even though it's not you're saying it's
not patriarchy but men are still staying
at the top you said it by having the
gender pay gap men are still at the top
because women are who are they catering
to
sorry who are they catering to men
that's not true 70 to 80 of consumer
buying decisions are made by women
so everything you're like why do we have
fat chicks in the media
why do we have fat checks in the media
oh fat chicks
oh are they catering to women
i agree yeah so i'm saying i'm saying
like victorious
so how is it a patriarchy if they're
catering to women because 70 to 80 of
consumer purchasing decisions are made
by women yeah but i think
you said that the um
it's based on men having to make
decisions on things and we're making
decisions based on personalities
and personality differences yeah okay
cool so yeah i
for me because you said that it actually
kind of altered my way of thinking
you saying that has made me think that
okay cool so biologically because men
think this way this is what stemmed into
them
building a patriarchy
maybe intentionally or not do you know
what i mean like the personality
difference may be the case as to why
this patriarchy has subsequently been
built do you get what i'm saying so
regard we can blame it on patriarchy
then we can then again blame it on
personality difference either way men
still stand at the top i'm not sure but
why is that a bad thing he said it
i'm not saying there's not a patriarchy
but like
the fact that remains is we've all seen
on on news there's been a whole conflict
going on
in
that whole region yeah what's the first
thing that happened
the women and children got shipped off
yeah
did they complain
they didn't say no no
no no i'm independent i'm gonna give me
a rifle no they didn't do those girls
that i've i spoke to around the time
were like yeah put me in the kitchen
brother you're nuts i ain't fighting
so when it suits them there's no
patriarchy or the patriarchy stays but
it suits them so what i'm saying is we
need to we need to like think of it
level-headed we can't blame something we
need to look okay look at why it's
happening but also see that things have
improved and now
if if you can't blame everything on one
thing now and women don't want equality
we don't if we wanted equality then we
would be in those positions like i do
like how is it how is it a patriarchy
when men men have the majority of hard
jobs men have the majority of suicide
but it's men have the majority men still
men still have the money
of the power
but how how do they have the power when
women make seventy to eighty percent of
consumer
decisions they're consuming decisions
but who are they buying from but who who
do they cater to they cater to who know
who do the people trying to make money
cater to
yes but the people who run the companies
uh-huh
are the men so what but again what is
the problem with that that doesn't mean
i never said
because we're talking about like who has
the most influence in a society and i
would say women okay i would say women
because we make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions so even if
it's not at the top they're catering to
women
if i don't make anything from it
so women have more influence yes and i
get it they're strengthening numbers you
know eight together strong however
who's making the money from the women
toby there's two types of people as well
as buyers and sellers not everyone is a
buyer but this is what i'm saying
the majority of people are consumers
but where you want to be no that's the
way you want to be that's what you
understand
they've got me and what what i'm saying
is the majority of people don't even
have they think the mindset of the oh
yeah i could make something inside yeah
other people can consume it the majority
of people are literally oh okay this
came out let me consume it oh this is
that then because they don't have them
in time let's let's talk about you know
the quickest
millionaires right now
only fans models where's the equality
what what's the equality what i will say
is why i really agree with your point is
we obviously our podcast we put a lot of
things on tick tock yes
whenever we have a female on it blows up
crazy any any clip of the club goes
crazy
and
yeah
but here's the thing no no no no no no
no no but here's the thing whenever we
have women influence within our tick
tocks or we've done our episodes that's
what does better well it's even you
like like i put you in the middle of my
thumbnail
oh my god like no
i'm so not dressed like that no you're
pr like like like i was like girls come
on like
in the front
you see girls yeah
they they flock to it guys and girls for
two different reasons but they they will
always go towards it yeah because they
have a reason
yeah there's a reason why girls get
certain things for french incentivize
more which is why i which is where when
pearl says only fans yeah which is why
girls get some i think it was her name
that freaking
52 million yeah 52 million first the
first favorite first of all men need to
be more stitched because what is that
what is this
i've never paid for you i've never i've
never paid for it i don't know if i've
ever
paid for nothing but you've seen it
obviously no
what i did see was before she turned 18
she hadn't had anything oh
[Music]
basically before she was 18 apparently
she'd have not noodie i know she was
even on the ship well i saw was an
article saying oh my baby's turn 18.
let's see what she posted before she was
18 was just her bikinis and [ __ ] that's
literally what i've seen for today
i couldn't tell you i could all i knew
was she tried to rap for the rest of
making
that's literally all i saw so
yeah her making money more power to her
but end the day i thought if you are if
you're a man or anybody and you're
seeing such a cheap price or something
it's something that you want to obtain
well the the issue the issue is that one
in three men um are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year what
under 30 under 30. yeah
that's insane that's what you're doing
yeah it's because 28 like 80 of women
want 20 percent of men so the reason
women hate men is we're all sleeping
with the same woman you're telling me
one of us
in the past
but all three of you could be in that
twenty percent though
i'm just saying that you could be let's
take it by the numbers right you guys
are over six foot yeah yes top 15
top 15 percent of guys just being over
six five
like you make over i don't know what it
would be here but like in the us if you
make over 70
000 that puts you in the top like
you guys
so so it's like you out you add all that
okay another question how many of you
how many of you guys have ever cheated
in a relationship
oh but that like kind of supports what
i'm saying um oh you were you were
arguing for something pretty pretty
heavy before the cameras
was all people
super chat they said the department of
education ministerial team is three
women and two men
so when you were saying earlier it's run
by men it's run by women yeah but that's
fine who's the who's in the house of
commons artsy than women in here
no i'm talking about for education
who watches that bro
the beauty industry is also run by women
top to bottom and then there's another
comment what industry story beauty and
there's another yeah for sure there's
another comment that says it doesn't
matter no company is going to make money
if they don't sell something
yeah so so like that's like it goes back
to like women have more influence than
men
okay i think as a whole i think no don't
be wrong i agree i agree i agree with
women having influence as consumers yeah
who's making the decisions
women wait hold on because because
because those guys won't be in power
unless women buy
yeah that's fine yeah but so women are
making the decisions but you still stay
in power
but you don't
you don't stay in power if you don't if
you don't sell i i i think that's
derivative i think even though you think
if no girl bought amazon and
i'm not saying that yeah okay okay sorry
products the women are gonna buy right
in the market i agree however
you as a man okay so if i was if i was
in amazon if i was the vp of sales okay
i have to look at what what the market's
doing what the trend is doing doesn't
matter if you're a man or a woman buying
my [ __ ] i'm just looking at what shit's
being bought
i don't care about whether you're a man
or woman they do right no i don't you
have to watch it yeah no i like you
that's marketing that's marketing you
literally have to look at no who's your
democracy did you did you hear what the
job description i just gave was uh-huh i
said vp of sales yeah i'm not a vp of
marketing i don't care about my
demographic what i care about is what do
you think data from marketing in order
to do oh you're being sold
i'm telling you guys
are you scott i'm telling you yeah
is
you have to know who you're
targeting yes of course that's the most
important thing of course you have to
know who the target market is right so
then what do you cater yourself what are
you catering do you know what products
you're selling the most
no what do you do you cater to the
target
market i'm not talking about okay that's
fine that's what who does that who
markets a product regardless of who does
it no no no no no you're you're a vp of
sales right yeah i'm sorry aren't you on
someone saying i'm not
it doesn't matter who buys the product
whoever buys the product fine it might
be mine it might be a woman okay okay
cool whatever happens if all i care
about selling the product what i'm gonna
do is make more of that product
did you get it the demand increases i
just increased the supply
to match the demand yes or no yeah yeah
yes so why so what i'm saying is i might
if my job isn't too much i get it you
have to market a product to make sure it
fits the consumer right 100 okay what
i'm saying is as much as the demand
might increase all i have to do is
increase the supply
what do you think it's that
you're using you're using a very
i get what you're saying you're not
wrong but like in a in a graphical sense
in a graphical sense that would just be
a general supply and demand graph but
then you have to dig deeper and then
look into
where where you're increasing the supply
because if you're if you're if if 45
year olds and over are buying it will
you increase the plan to 25 dollars what
do you do
i agree i agree but that's that's a
marketing
story i feel like they oh
[Applause]
if you're in charge of sales so i used
to sell copiers right
you as a vp of sales you have to know
your target market and train the sales
people to know who they're selling to so
then who are you catering to
no no i agree you're carrying to that
demographic yourself which is mostly in
70 to 80 percent of the time what
women
who has more influence
if
the guys at the top are catering to who
women
however so how is it a patriarchy if the
guys at the top are catering to who
okay women
so how is it a patriarchy what i'm
saying is the men still stand on the top
because most women don't want to work 80
hours a week their whole life and i i
my dad's in the top half a percent of
earners okay
very very successful i don't know
many men or women would you say i'll go
towards your dad
again
okay um okay but but
most people didn't want to do what he
did
do you want to work 80 hours a week for
30 40 years
most people don't and women especially
especially over like over a certain age
they want to spend time at home with the
kids so i just don't understand how it's
how it's a patriarchy if the guys at the
top are catering to women
and women are choosing not to work those
jobs
i think i think what you're saying is
slightly being twisted in the fact that
you're saying that women have most
influence on buying the products which i
understand or buying
in general consuming
but like you said women statistically
aren't working or don't want to work or
don't negotiate a salary
whatever it may be don't do what men do
yeah to get to the top yes and then to
me that
goes straight back to the personality
differences yes yes so what i'm saying
is men think a certain way has caused
them to act in certain ways and to build
on it through their personality
differences has caused them to be at the
top of patients right triangle right
consumers are at the bottom
correct
all the people which are mainly women
yes of course they'll have more
influence because there's multiple of
them when you get to the top
they're all men
they're catering to i understand i
understand i agree because my point
still remains in the day the suppliers
it's still going to be the men it's
going to be the people that are at the
top in the vp of whatever role you might
be catering to whoever at the bottom
you're selling people with the power and
you're saying that women have the most
influence to influence a product or
where it's put or you know how it's
marketed i get that however whoever is
getting their actual money you're buying
something for one pound that person will
talk to make one million of it but then
because because eighty percent of women
are making that decision but then you're
assuming that everyone wants to be a
buyer how
it comes
like patriarchy like it sounds like
there's something in the way of people
from like doing those roles
and i'm saying i think it's easier for
women to get to those those roles but
they just don't want to
i think i think like
there are specific there are specific
grants for women that are not offered to
men
so how how is it easier for for men
for men so right now if you went into if
you went into it if you wanted to there
are quotas for one if you want to there
are quotas for a woman if you went to a
company and this guy down yeah if you
went to a company white men at the top
that was my last company i worked at
yeah oh that's what it was yeah
you always want to hire someone who
looks like you that's just not true
matter men are attracted to younger
women so they're way more willing to
help
i'm sorry that's so that's so true look
at kamala harris
how did she might be put to
discrimination why
still do you not see more people of
color more people that are of different
genders or different um
[Music]
two separate issues don't talk about
sexual orientation that's not looking
for
sexual orientation at the top i mean
would you do what happens with them
these you're talking about in one
specific community we're talking about
in general when has people with
different sexual orientations ever been
at the top
when
when in any industry has it ever been
equal
ever
in any industry let's let's take like i
don't think it comes right so i'm saying
how can you say it's a it's a patriarchy
when in different industries it's
different like the modeling industry
women make more money in the nba like
there's like in the nba
like like that's what i'm saying they're
in different industries different people
dominate because one thing you have to
take into account is cultural
differences like certain cultures value
different things
like i'm i'm um german germans tend to
be engineers
all my brothers are engineers is that is
that because of the patriarchy or is it
because germans like to be engineers
um
yeah i'm an engineer
no what i mean in terms of in terms of
being a patriarchy like what would
equality look like to you sorry go ahead
i just meant typically
stay at the top in my england my english
in england i'm in today
in england i'm in today i feel like if i
went into it if i got highly accompanied
i would see white men
in most companies i would walk into in
london or in england i think they're
trying to change that i agree that's why
i think it's easy but that's why i think
it's easier because they're trying to
change that there's things like quotas
like at the company i worked at there
was quotas for women they couldn't get a
shitty job selling copiers don't
recommend it don't do it
but like like like they couldn't get
women to take the job and keep it but i
got special treatment as a girl
so so how is it harder
i
to do what sorry how is it harder to
make it to the top like that was a
company where like white men were at the
top but i was getting special treatment
as a girl
where i would like there was a quota so
i could get the job easier there was
women only grants in the company so i
could move up easier
how on earth is there a patriarchy if i
haven't eaten i wouldn't necessarily say
that it's
so i wouldn't necessarily say it's more
difficult okay
what i would say is if i was a man that
looked like
whoever is hiring me or the last my
predecessor is going to be easier for me
to get in that way
even if there's a quota
even if there's a quota on the company
gets a tax break
for for hiring either for
it's more likely
but
because obviously men have that
mentality to do these types of roles but
it's actually physically easier like for
example i work in the tech industry i
work for a cyber security company so
like
i'm always getting like female
developers working with female
developers they are sought after in the
market yeah
impossible to find and we will move the
heaven and earth to get a female
developer do you know what i mean right
as a man there will be a guy who went
cambridge
everything
like he's just another guy yeah i mean
i agree i agree with that 100
right so it's easier for women you agree
i think
i said music
no i agree
my first point my first point is
definitely not more difficult for a
woman
okay so what i'm saying is if i wanted
to uh
unless you gave an example if you have a
tax break
right finally one woman don't know yeah
if i'm getting hired by somebody to take
over that role and i look like them i
have a very good chance of getting hired
into that role
even if there's a quota
then yeah obviously it's different i
mean i don't know how many companies
have a quota i have no idea
pretty much every company now what to be
put into like an executive vp role yeah
yeah that's how it
that's what i is talking about before
women don't want to do those roles they
don't want to work 80 hours a week they
don't want to do so you're saying the
reason i don't see them is because they
don't want to be there yes
yes and and the other problem is you're
not you're you're what does equality
look like like like you you don't even
have like it's not going to be 50 50 no
matter what
so if we take the beauty industry it's
mostly women if we take the teaching
industry it's most
women if we take the engineering
industry it's mostly meant like people
choose things based on personality
differences
i i agree with you
i can i can kind of like chime in on
that because when i started like
videography and stuff and i was like
jumping in different different like some
some streets i was i was dope some sort
of director of some shoes i was
producing and the woman come up to me he
was like ah what you want to do i was
like i'll direct him but producers want
a bank she got gas she was like oh my
god thank you we need more men only
women choose this in my head i'm like
right so there are literally like
there are jobs out there that solely
women gravitate to because there's bear
women in the creative industry but
there's hardly any female directors i
agree
i agree with you like but what you said
what quality looks like for me equality
isn't
the equality is you are literally
getting chosen on your skill that's it
you're getting chosen how good you are
whatever you're doing
everyone gets the same opportunity okay
so then so so then my question is one
would you be against quotas then
and two
how how do you know the difference
so like like so if white men just happen
to be at the top because
like how do you know the difference
between it not be like because you're
assuming it's like a patriarchy here's
the thing if it is equal and white women
on the top the white men are at the top
because they're better yeah it is equal
right
right
shut up whatever here's the thing if if
it is equal right
in my eyes they're at the top because
they're better if what is equal if
everyone has the same opportunity
remember we're in a white dominated
country though of course and i don't i
don't expect anything more i could
people say do you see this [ __ ] but
i'm not trying to say that because
there's 25 percent black people in this
country
oh sorry in this london
that's not why i'm saying that's not
what i said but but i'm asking you what
what like why is your why is your
immediate assumption that it's a
patriarchy and they're not just the ones
that worked hard to get there
because it's been because nothing has
happened
in my opinion nothing substantial has
happened to change the fact like quotas
everyone's getting the same opportunity
like quotas yeah quotas happen of course
yeah every single company and not
everyone's getting the same opportunity
i've been in london my entire life as
have these two men
i traveled
i was born in italy shut up right so
i've been in london my whole life so i
see the different opportunities people
getting i see how different people get
treated in interviews and different
workplaces and i know for a fact
different opportunities people are
getting and i still wear to you right
people are getting extra opportunities
and are definitely getting more
in workplaces than any black man i've
ever seen
so anyway so are we switching it to race
because i thought we were talking about
gender i mean you could talk about how
you do it okay right no because we've
just been talking about gender right and
i okay yeah i can't speak for a woman i
can't speak for a woman i have three
sisters but i can't speak yeah
about the
whatever they face at work i can't
so i'm talking from my opinion right
right but i'm saying yes you can you can
like i mean i i can't why not
i mean i can say what i think i can't
tell you for a fact i can't okay i mean
i've never been treated as a woman right
half of me right but like but like
but they both were talking about how
like he was saying how
like women are picked faster in his
industry yeah and i'm saying i was
obviously i'm yeah i'm in i'm in the
engineering industry right and they
would love
different women to come in as a
developer or as a as a chemical engineer
or even as you know some of the
don't care just having more women and
happier okay
so it's easier for women
and there's no patriarchy then
that doesn't mean that there's no
paycheck because some things are easy
for me
because egypt gets in at the bottom
entry level doesn't mean but it's easier
to get in at the top too because you can
market it like female-led ceos are
heavily marketed i mean
i i'll i'll be real i have to see some
if i swallow stop great you could tell
me i'm wrong okay would you change your
opinion yeah if you had the numbers to
like back it up would you change your
opinion tell me i'm wrong i think you're
wrong
well what
huh no i'm saying like like so if i
showed you the numbers like your face
happy okay honestly i'm open to anything
i'm not gonna tell you like i was just
wondering yeah i'm open like if you told
me yeah this is you know these right
numbers and actually more women in in
senior roles from vp and blah blah blah
yes sorry i was wrong yeah you told me
that's calm um i'm going to read super
chats real quick
sorry
when was the last one we read um
um is that is it the 100 one is that the
first one or is there one before that
two more before that two more um okay
read the first one i i'll start with
semaine tegan so you do the one before
that um real femme sapien
love you stay fabulous
thank you ally okay i'm smee and taken
the department for education ministerial
team is three women and two men beauty
industries also one run by women top to
bottom okay i saw that one the other one
was a
let's see hey
a hundred dollar super chat
okay um chris and um the guy arguing is
emotional
arguing with feelings over facts please
take away his mankind
i donated 100 super chat so many times
that i just noticed my name is at the
top of the screen a few times
five dollars the spoken nun um that you
would see white men at the top in
england because it is in a majority
white country
um the
i was at the end of them okay cool cool
cool
um
give me the facts
give me the phone
okay um one more thing before we close
out the show so um
one thing we always talk about
with like modern women is getting money
right
now
recently there was an ig model
um
that came out and said she was flown out
to dubai
have you seen it
i didn't mean to i was scarred
no don't do it
don't do it so okay there was a girl who
was gang banged by over 20 saudi royalty
we watched the worst video we watched
she was urinated and pooped oh yeah
objects up her yeah and she said she
made 40k in two days so it was worth it
40 bucks
say it i thought it was like a mill bro
and again then
again it's a pandemic number deeper
deeper deeper you've done that in two
days and now you have our house
i saw a tick tock actually yesterday
about a girl and she showed her dms and
how they like recruit
and then like they literally listed the
weirdest [ __ ] like you have to have a
foot fetish you have to have fetish of
like touching the under of your nails
obviously pooping
the page actually right it's crazy i'm
gonna say on camera but i'll expose it
afterwards
i'm not in it
everyone knows what that is where they
expose people in it that
so when you see it go just in dubai by
yourself but i
suppose i said this is
i saw the video i didn't mean to but i
was looking up articles before the show
and i was like and it came up like in
one of the articles so i was like oh no
bro i can't see that
the video
there's other videos of like there's
other videos of like
like women getting like [ __ ] by dogs
yeah i've seen that oh that was fun
watch that with straight faces i said
that's
me right now that's normal
so if a woman does this can we [ __ ]
shame or not
sorry quick one what's wrong she does
that getting shot on in the mouth or
getting [ __ ] by a dog
getting shot in the mouth
feces in your mouth
so would you have beyonce's faces in
your mouth
okay then
any amount of money could any amount of
money did we have 40k in two days yeah
40k in two days would you let would you
let women poop in your mouth nope
nope
i would love to but i just can't i just
call it
it needs to be enough to make that
person disappear in the whole family
no there needs to be no loose ends
and the guy that paid you 10 mil
probably has like a whole security
detail on everything
wow i really feel like i need five
minutes to change my life
that's the only time i consider it will
change your life
what i'm saying is
i right now i'm not like oh i mean i
need a five mil would have to be like
some squid game type [ __ ]
what i mean
it's true though stick in a bigger hole
i would need to be like i need i need
this even considering okay
so if you needed it how much
well i don't know because i don't need
it yet
that's what i mean
if you needed like if you saw it someone
told you
someone told you you need a hundred bags
someone said
someone said
let's say
you're in the hood
100 bags when you're going to die
you die yeah oh i'm taking it i'm i'll
be rude i'm taking the [ __ ] bro
[Music]
to survive
that's what i'm saying if i needed the
money i needed it and yeah cool consider
it
i follow my pride every day
to the ladies and in that case and i you
asked this earlier should she be
slut-shamed
it just comes down to what slash it just
comes down to us
no but if you think about it no because
if you think about you guys were saying
oh should she be shamed for sleeping
with those people yeah oh wait didn't
sleep with most people yeah i thought
she's getting she got objects up in her
mouth
oh [ __ ] okay i mean
it comes down to the fact that you can
swatch them but depends on whether or
not they take it
if they she really wanted to get i don't
care i got 4k
listen i'd rather you know before i said
i wouldn't like if a girl had over 10.
i would rather her have 20 than have had
[ __ ] in her mouth
[Laughter]
like once you've done that once it's
over for me
you're a little even a little oh [ __ ]
[Music]
do you think she the girl's empowered in
that case she's us
no if she in the in the dubai model is
she empowered
empowered by what she's diminishing she
gets her own money she makes her own bag
wow
do you think feminists should be
fighting for those women or do you know
it's their own choice
they want the money it's fair enough i
know i think yeah i think they should be
yeah they'll fight i think that should
be fine for those women i [ __ ] dare
you of course you should be like well
it's too much to be have [ __ ] in your
mouth there should be no limits to
feminism wait
actually
are you saying are you sorry but would
you fight for men that have [ __ ] in
their mouth
men women children nobody
who the [ __ ] fight for everyone's [ __ ]
in your mouth you're crazy
no
i i think i think there should be no
bounds to feminism how do you go
yourself and feminists
that should be 100
what that should be
there's one thing that i don't agree
with when it comes to feminism because
they i feel like feminism like feminist
females have to pick and choose when
they want to be feminists okay because
like say if i punch you right now you
have the right to punch me back 100
but some feminists would be like no
no i shouldn't get punched back because
i have a female hit the bitch's movement
my sisters i wouldn't call them i
wouldn't call it a feminist i'll call
them quite traditional if you punch me
in the face there's no way to let me
punch you back
i personally would i'll fight for you
know i can't lie i wouldn't punch anyone
in the face without having to
like doesn't matter if you did i might
want to punch you in the face
because you're a woman i'll i'll fight
for you you can
god
if anyone i fight
should like i should expect to be
like get here
that's because of the consequences of
doing that you that's not because if i
bring race into it it's going to even
get longer but let's just say you as a
man
the moment you you touch her you're
finished for life bro
you're done unless you just run
yeah
[Laughter]
those women are fighting for you to be
able to competition fight for me
equal rights equal laughs baby
no no to that extent i agree they
shouldn't be fighting for your corner
because you participate first yeah they
shouldn't have i agree they should be
fighting for equality if we're fighting
for equality that's equality
i agree like if chris was a woman
he should have been able to rightfully
hit will smith
tell you what yeah you should be able to
get back anyway
what was she saying if will smith was a
woman okay okay
all black people
[Music]
because a lot of people call themselves
feminists but they actually hate men or
they like
um
when it comes to feminism i feel like
real people who are actually that hot
like
proper feminists get [ __ ] on because of
these people here that's what i'm saying
i agree with like equality and
um
like 50 50. i think there'll ever
honestly i think most like feminists
like they are crazy they're crazy
has no direction right now it needs a
man at the top
[Music]
what are we fighting for in
2022 but we don't have we have all our
rights yes if anything i want to return
rights if anything i would say
this is what i'm saying i'm kind of like
what can someone tell me what a woman
doesn't have
that we have
i don't know is what's happening with
this abortion thing happening in the usa
i don't know about it yeah but i would
say i know in texas they made that [ __ ]
illegal to have yeah state by state like
no yeah of course it's step by step but
still there's still some person saying
you cannot afford a baby
it's not that simple i remember reading
the article
we shouldn't be able to
we should we we could buy it we can't do
it
if you got raped if i got raped i would
keep it i don't believe
no why would you do that though why
because i don't believe in killing a
child and besides
and like to be honest you're moving the
argument because you're taking less than
one percent of cases so most cases
aren't in the case case of right okay
but if it is okay let's give you the
case of race yeah all the other ones are
legal
how are all the other ones no she said
she's saying i'll give you i'll give you
saying have rate final yeah and all the
other ones all the other ones should be
like so i don't think they're happy they
will
no they should be illegal
just because you made poor decisions
like don't like close your legs
yeah be right right you're looking
you're looking for the exception rather
than the rule even even when they even
when they survey women on like why
they're getting an abortion it's left
less than 15 okay fair enough most of
them weren't even wearing condoms even
if we are talking about the rule i still
think a woman should choose whether or
not she can do and what she wants to do
with her body it's up to you whether you
want to keep the child i don't know if
you would do the same or whatever but at
the same time
if you want to abort a baby you can do
that because that's your body that's
your choice it's different when you
don't want to compare to someone else
who isn't even a woman telling you
what you can and can't do to your own
body well you realize in some of those
states like women past those like in
georgia women
a woman passed the law
so how can you like so that argument
doesn't really you also look at the
exception in that instance because as a
rule there's a lot of men are you are
you sure about that 100 you're 100 sure
that all of the like when congress is 50
women in the united states
no i can't be 100 sure that the majority
of men are both um passing laws to a boy
but i can be a hundred percent sure that
the majority of this
like for example okay people in texas
agree with that
agree with elite okay i know you're kind
of moving the goal post here yeah
because i i asked you if you were 100
percent sure if it was 50 percent then
at 50
oh no i'm not there
making the laws yeah okay i'm not 100
okay but i know for a fact men do have a
high significant percentage of that in
regards to making abortion legal
but but i'm saying if congress is half
and half in the united states
how how can you say that what you mean
like you're saying it's men passing
though and i don't really think it
matters who's passing the law to be
honest right like like i just think it's
it's should abortion be legal or illegal
and and uh what's happening in the u.s
isn't even banning abortion it's leaving
the rights up to the states because
there's a misinterpretation of the
constitution right so so basically like
when the founders created the
constitution there's no way they were
thinking about abortion
like
[ __ ] was within it no
it was that's what they're saying
because roe versus wade say it was
saying abortion should be legal
because they there's a right to privacy
yeah but that's a stretch
like there's no way when the founders
were creating the constitution when
abortion wasn't even a thing back then
that they were saying in the right to
private
well it wasn't common not before the 19
like it was legalized in the 1900s right
so so i'm saying that you weren't doing
that anyway either right right but i'm
saying the founders when they were
writing that document we're not thinking
hmm like let's put abortions under
privacy
okay yeah so so roe versus wade
said that in all 50 states
regardless of what the people want in
those states that they that abortion is
going to be illegal
and so now they're saying no that was a
misinterpretation right each state
should decide for themselves right
so
do you see what i'm saying so it's not
banning abortion
it was still illegal
in some states it was still illegal no
it can't be illegal because of roe
versus wade it was it was no no there
was a certain it was after like four
weeks i don't know the exact number of
weeks but after a certain amount of
weeks it was illegal it can't be
completely banned because of roe versus
weight okay well for a period of time it
was illegal
no it can't be because of roe versus
wade but it now it can be if assuming
they do overturn that
right you see i'm saying kind of yeah
but i just think like it's it's based on
your decisions no i do think it's
basically yeah i don't think so
you're how your body works and what you
want to do should be based on something
else
you should come back tomorrow though
that's our topic tomorrow so
we can we can we can talk more about it
tomorrow i actually want to know what's
going on
yeah yeah
that's i'll come i'll come better with
like
the whole thing so if you want to come
tomorrow like we could actually
i won't i won't put everyone through
this
um okay
but um okay guys thank you for coming i
know we have a lot of tech difficulties
today so i appreciate you guys like
sticking through with us for that i mean
you guys want to go around tell them
where they can find you also guys all
their links are in the description and
um you really should follow um these two
have
a really funny podcast and i just found
out you have a youtube channel
the links to that are in the description
you guys should check those out but go
ahead
engel a o um l y e n g e l e and on
shambles fm also i'm going to be
submitting my cv to lead the feminist
movement because i think they need me
my name is yasmin i'm 20. did we do that
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
um i guess instagram i am yazzy
yeah my name is
jacob and obviously yeah follow me on
youtube tick tock basically everything
tj's world
i got my own oh yeah [ __ ]
uh i go by toby my instagram is at
boy i ain't going to tell you
i'll spell that [ __ ]
i think it's in the instagram me in the
comment below so you know
also
on youtube spotify all of that
follow up and i'll be lovely thank you
my name is amani and uh you can find me
on tick tock at amani i'm just going to
xlx
um okay before we close the show i'm
going to read um do you have the other
super chats hold up i'm going to read
the ones that are at the bottom
sometimes they disappear on my phone
guys that's why okay um 4.99 from 90
frito p all of you need to listen to
patrice o'neill versus dr zodak women
have no original arguments ever also
killing babies is wrong always
um
i don't see any other super chat
um
and then
um we
we have a super chat from the spoken one
uh men being at the top isn't that also
a result of hypergamy slash woman's
dating preferences
also another one from the spoken one uh
you would see white men at the top in
england because it's a majority white
that's
country
that's been said yeah
okay guys um
well thank you so much for tuning in um
i really appreciate you guys helping out
um in the comments with like the tech
issues so um
really appreciate that thank you so much
for watching don't forget to subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
bell and i will talk to you guys next
time